you've definitely seen her somewhere or
everywhere at the age of 16 mckenna
grace has managed to make her way into
almost every single movie and tv show to
ever exist think that's an exaggeration
stay tuned to learn about the other
projects that paige from young sheldon
has been in
before mckenna was in gifted she had
already done more than a dozen
television roles including 50 episodes
of the long-running soap opera the young
and the restless
she had also taken parts in several
movies but her role in gifted is one she
may very well be typecast in a child
prodigy mckenna starred as
seven-year-old mary adler in 2017's
gifted which was filmed in 2015. she
portrayed a character who becomes the
subject of a custody battle between her
uncle frank and her grandmother evelyn
mary's mother diane died by suicide
seemingly from the stress she put
herself through obsessively trying to
solve the navier stokes problem frank
wants mary to have a chance at a normal
life fearing that a school for the
intellectually gifted could put her on a
path that would mirror her mother's but
evelyn was dedicated to seeing diane
solve the problem and wants to encourage
mary's intellect to be developed to its
full potential grace won a couple of
awards on the festival circuit for her
turn as mary she took home the 2017
awards for breakthrough performance and
best performance by a youth from the
phoenix films critics society she was
also nominated for the broadcast film
critics association's award for best
young actor and the women film critics
circle award for best young actress
in 2017 mckenna grace made the
transition from child prodigy to child
skating superstar for the dark comedy i
tonya based loosely on real life events
the film stars margot robbie as
controversial figure skater tanya
harding it tells the tale of her
formative years and the events leading
up to the january 1994 attack on fellow
figure skater nancy kerrigan an assault
in which harding's husband jeff glooly
was also implicated mckenna plays a
young tanya harding in flashback
sequences she's bullied and harassed by
her mother lavonna golden who aims to
mold tanya into a champion i tanya
explores the dysfunctional and abusive
relationships that comprise tanya's life
presenting her in a more sympathetic
light than any media coverage she'd
received in the fallout from the
kerrigan attack writer stephen rodgers
interviewed harding and glooly
separately noting that the two principal
parties had differing accounts of how
the events had unfolded during a panel
for the sag-aftra foundation rogers said
i thought well that's my way in i'll
just put everybody's point of view up
there and then let the audience decide
grace described her role as the young
harding as the most challenging role
she'd ever done because of one big
factor she had to learn to ice skate she
told the boston globe i've never done
ice skating before i'd fall and i was
all beaten up but i had to get up and
keep trying it's a sentiment that
mirrors tanya's troubled life as seen in
the film
life can change pretty quickly for kids
on a network tv drama one minute your
father is the outgoing secretary of
housing and urban development who wasn't
invited to the state of the union
address and then suddenly he's the
president of the united states that's
what happened to penny kirkman whose
father tom was chosen for the title
position on abc's political thriller
drama designated survivor when president
robert richmond addresses the nation in
front of both congress and the supreme
court an explosion rocks the capitol
building killing almost everyone inside
and leaving the country without a
working government except for tom
kirkman that is who was selected by
president richmond to not attend this
was to maintain the line of succession
so he suddenly elevated to the role of
president
sounds like a decent consolation prize
for not being invited to a party that
while memorable ended pretty badly
mckenna's role as first daughter penny
kirkman included sporadic appearances as
a recurring character rather than as a
member of the main cast she appeared in
21 of the series 53 episodes including
seven of the ten episodes in season
three which was produced and released on
netflix when abc decided not to renew
the show after season two in an
interview with red carpet news tv grace
said she enjoyed being part of her
designated survivor television family
calling kiefer sutherland and tv mom
natasha mcelhone both very very nice and
kind people she also revealed something
she has in common with her tv dad they
both have stuffed animals in their
trailers
shirley jackson's 1959 horror novel the
haunting of hill house has been directly
adapted three times twice for the big
screen in 1963 and 1999 there were the
hauntings and then there was the first
installment of netflix's the haunting
anthology series the haunting of hill
house
every incarnation of the tale involves
the supernatural goings-on at hill house
a sweeping country mansion nestled in
the hills the netflix series tells the
story of the crane family and their
experiences over the course of two
timelines 26 years apart at the spooky
location
father hugh crane has purchased hill
house and is renovating it to sell for a
tidy profit in the meantime he's moved
his wife olivia son stephen and luke and
daughters shirley theodora and nell into
the mansion
from there things go about as well as
you'd expect them to for a series with
the word haunting in the title
grace plays the young version of theo
the middle child who's arguably the most
well adjusted she also wears gloves all
the time it's not because she's a
germaphobe or something weird like that
unless of course you count having extra
sensory perception and experiencing
people's thoughts and feelings through
tactile contact is weird
living in the reality of the handmaid's
tale sounds pretty terrifying it's
reasonable to think that surviving a
coup would require some grit and
determination but then there's
witnessing the overthrow of one's
homeland at the hands of radicals who
then institute martial law and enslave
women as broodmares plus there's the
backdrop of declining human fertility
already wreaking havoc in society
dealing with all this without losing
one's mind is a huge intimidating task
thus many of the characters on the
popular hulu series have been hardened
by their experiences especially the
title handmaid june osborne it's through
this hardening that she has been able to
effectively resist and break her
shackles she rescues dozens of children
in the process via the angel's flight in
season three naturally that kind of
notoriety brings with it certain
expectations as seen through the eyes of
esther keyes the extremely young wife of
commander keys esther offers june and
the other escaped handmaid's refuge at
her farm at the beginning of the
handmaid's tale season 4. mrs keys is
strict and demanding with an insatiable
appetite for vengeance and the
devastating explanation for that is
revealed by the end of the season
premiere
grace expressed her excitement at
playing esther keys in an interview with
elle saying i thought she was so cool
she's such an interesting character to
play especially with how intimidating
she is the way she switches from being
so anxious and upset to if you weren't
going to fight then you shouldn't come
here she's angry and then she's regal
and talking to the guards she changes up
so quickly
the sitcom full house launched the
careers of many prominent child actors
including candace cameron beret jody
sweeten and twins mary-kate and ashley
olsen after that the netflix revival
show fuller house gave visibility to a
whole new generation of young talents
including mckenna grace
set in the same san francisco townhouse
as the original series and focusing on
the now grown tanner siblings as they
raise children grace appeared on eight
episodes of fuller house across four
seasons of the show her role rose heifer
pfizer harbenberger an elementary school
student and daughter of cj harbenberger
the new partner of dj's old boyfriend
steve she also starts a cute schoolyard
romance with dj's son max
i'm the king of the world
being a part of fuller house was
personally fulfilling and important to
grace as she wrote on instagram i'll
never forget sitting on the full house
couch talking with bob saget i had
watched every episode of afv and full
house and i was so excited
for a few years mckenna grace
established a small niche for herself as
the go-to young actor to play child or
tween versions of characters she
somewhat resembles in the 2019 marvel
cinematic universe entry captain marvel
the launch of brie larson's take on the
intergalactic superhero grace portrayed
carol danvers as a child in a few
sequences she also stood in for kiernan
shipka playing the child version of
sabrina spellman on an episode of
netflix's chilling adventures of sabrina
finally in the 2021 horror movie
malignant about an adult woman who was
tormented by hallucinations of horrific
murders mckenna played the kid version
of the main character portrayed by
annabelle wallace in the rest of the
film as mckenna told teen vogue i like
to make a joke that i play the younger
versions of so many people i like to say
you know if they ever do a biopic of
finn or something i'm playing the
younger version of him
she was of course talking about her
ghostbusters afterlife on-screen sibling
finn wolfhard speaking of which
potentially the biggest and most visible
project to date in the growing career of
mckenna grace is her central role in
ghostbusters afterlife the 2021 entry in
the comic sci-fi series that started way
back in 1984 with ghostbusters set more
than 30 years after the events of the
original movie ghostbusters afterlife
finds a mom moving her kids to a new
house in a new town there they learn of
their connection to the spirit-sucking
heroes who save new york more than once
starring opposite carrie [ __ ] as her
mother and finn wolfhard as her brother
is grace as young would-be ghostbuster
phoebe ghostbuster's afterlife was a 200
million dollar box office hit in the age
of covet affected theater attendants and
that was more than enough to prompt sony
to order a sequel meaning grace has
gotten herself an important role in a
major film franchise before she's even
old enough to vote
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]